so one of the best things that I do is
that I'm I co-direct a group of the
Canadian Institute for Advanced Research
it has a new name and it's called child
and brain development and I do that with
Professor tomboys who's sitting in the
front row and one of the things that
we're interested in is how our
experience gets embedded in our biology
and a group of us have met with autism
researchers and clinicians to talk about
the themes that have come out of the
last ten years of our research program
that addresses these issues and which
one of them of them might be relevant
for questions around autism so one of
the things we can ask in this room is
why are we all different and and many
many years ago you might have heard
people say well it's all nurture we're
born as a blank slate and the
environment writes on it whereas another
group might have said maybe a biologist
like me that nature is really important
it's all in our genes and now we know
that this nature dichotomy eicher
nurture dichotomy is dead in fact we
can't even take how much is nature in
the genes and add it to how much is
nurture in the environment and add those
together and say well that's why we have
these individual differences in fact
there's an interaction between the
genetics and our environment and these
genes that predispose us to behave in
certain ways or to allow give us certain
risks for certain disorders they come in
different forms and some of them buffer
our experience or our brain development
and some of us make our our brain
development and the behavioral outcome
from that behavioral development be more
susceptible and so we can see that we
have different genetic variants many of
them have been identified those lots of
them and some of us protect us whereas
others make us more susceptible and
within a typical normal population
tomboys and others have said that some
of our children when they're born are
like orchids whereas others are like
dandelions and so the Danny line
kid that is not sensitive to context
particularly could be transplanted from
place to place it doesn't matter too
much what happens to that child in terms
of its early experience it's always
going to do pretty well whereas the
orchid child needs to like probably my
two kids need to be watered and kept in
the right humidity and then they
flourish and so far mine are flourishing
where is it that orchid child is born
into a neglect or born into misfortune
than they do really poorly and so there
are genes that predispose all of us to
be buffered from certain environments to
really do exceptionally well given what
we experience and these are some of the
things that we study in fact our genes
are listening to the environment the DNA
is is static and that is there in all
our cells and it's all the same but it's
listening in the sense that it responds
by the the jeans the jeans make proteins
they make chemicals and the amount of
that protein or where it puts that
protein is it going to put it in the
liver in the neuron and another cell has
to do with the environment that that for
instance developing brain experiences in
utero and also whence the child is born
and we know now that there's this new
area the called epigenetics and it's
been all over the paper you might have
heard about it and this is a mechanism
for nurture it's a way that we now
understand how our experience gets
embedded in our biology and so if you
take identical twins their DNA is the
same and yet you probably all know
identical twins and as they grow up you
see quite a few differences it could be
differences in temperament in the way
that they look and if we then go in and
look at their DNA we find that DNA is
wrapped around these proteins called
chromatin and when it's wrapped around
that DNA does not end up being
particularly expressed but when the DNA
opens into a more open conformation than
it does get expressed and so our
environment acts like a dimmer switch to
change the expression of our genes the
amount of enzyme in our brain for
instance in a certain place and
and it goes up and down and that depends
on our early experience and also our
experience as we go through through
adolescence so we can think about these
gene-environment interactions in that
way and we've been studying the
mechanism and the next five years we're
trying to understand how these molecules
are regulated in the developing brain
how the body is talking to the brain and
how we arrived at individual differences
according to the susceptibility genes
and this epigenetic phenomenon and and
then finally the other big area in our
group has to do with critical or
sensitive periods and development and
this is pioneered by takeo hench who is
at our meeting from Harvard University
and you may know that our brains are
like sponges right we always say oh my
two year olds brain is like a sponge and
really our brains have windows of
opportunity that open and close and
during development when you if you're
pregnant and you're let's say six months
pregnant around that time if you play
that baby music my son would say play
the baby jazz some of you might like
Baca and others might like rock and that
once that baby comes out it can
distinguish between the type of music
that it's hurt or if you play from Janet
workers work in British Columbia if you
play different sounds from from your
language like da English or a dog which
I can't say in Hindi but it sounds
different when that baby emerges it will
have been had that exposure about
language and it will know the difference
between those sounds and then that
window of opportunity closes and by the
time you get like me and you try and
learn another language for sure you're
going to have an accent so there's
windows of opportunities for our for
listening for seeing for language and
also for social behavior and so later on
children learn how to regulate their
social behavior how to have social
cognition how to read social situations
and we know that this window that opens
and closes is regulated by molecules
that to cow and others have discovered
and he and others are able to open that
window closed it make it longer and make
it shorter and and he and others think
that this
windows these windows and brain
development and this and information
coming in may have something to do with
how that brain is wired differently or
not and so that's another very
interesting area of relevance so when
one I'm just going to finish up now so
when one thinks about normal or typical
variation in all these different traits
that have to do with autism we if one
thinks about that we all know people who
are more shy socially or check their
door before they leave several times I
mean with me it's always where's my key
and some of us are better communicating
verbally as compared to in writing and I
think if we graph the abilities of the
people in this room looking at many of
these different characteristics that we
are associating with autism at least in
a quantitative way we would see that
there's no one control there's nothing
that is okay we're going to compare it
to that in fact we have this huge
distribution and then the same is true
for the autistic kids right it's the
same kind of huge variation from one end
to the other in the spectrum and then
we're trying to figure out well what is
a control who should we be comparing
with whom in our experiments and so I
think one of the things we've we've
realized in the last few days is we need
to pay particular attention to the way
we phenotype that is how we quantify
these traits not just quality in that
you have it or you don't but what are
the how do we measure those things and I
lost my train of thought and I supposed
to do that when you're talking in public
but anyways so you're right and so so
that would that should be informed and
not only that but we don't only want to
quantify where those individuals sit in
the typical atypical population but we
know things change in development you're
on a developmental trajectory and so
there's a developmental way of thinking
that something happens at this time
that's going to fact what happens later
and that's true with behavior and brain
development and all those time periods
interact so that in the end you have you
have a grown-up human being and so these
this way of thinking which doesn't
particularly focus on autism or
schizophrenia
alzheimers how the the typical brain
develops and the requirement for that
development to optimize health and
promote optimal well-being for every
child which is one of the focuses of our
group those findings and the things that
we're discussing I think have been
really relevant and exciting and it's
been great to interact with the
clinicians and the researchers